by the grace of Allah subhah wa ta'ala
the response has been overwhelming to
say the very least alhamdulillah we've
had social media personalities and
respected Scholars from many parts of
the Muslim world promoting the cause we
have raised almost 1.4 million
alhamdulillah and we haven't been
sitting idly waiting to hit our Target
of 2 million we have fully purchased
four properties in andon transferred
their ownership to the W after the help
of Allah subhanahu wa tala none of this
would be possible without your support
so we thank you once again this is our
update to yourselves we encourage you to
stay tuned for more updates now that the
work alhamdulillah is truly
underway brothers and sisters and dear
friends this was a beautiful message
that I saw that was sent to me by uh a
brother and it is Ronaldo's message to
the Syrian people and what they're going
through I mean this guy guy is famous
many people who who are famous they
become arrogant we know in the Quran
about far he thought he was God he
thought he said I am Allah this how
arrogant it becomes money wealth makes
you feel like you're untouchable you
know and that's what Allah says in the
Quran that we send them signs and signs
until they basically paraphrasing that
they rejected rejected and Allah says we
open the doors of everything to them and
when they think they are at their Peak
we will snatch their soul Subhan Allah
what an disgusting end but Subhan Allah
Ronaldo and like people I've done a
video about him
officially he interested in Islam and he
can be accepting Islam anytime soon but
in this video we're going to wish for
ourselves is his message to the Syrian
people which is heartwarming let's watch
it for ourself in hello this is for
children of Syria we know that you have
been suffering a lot I am a very famous
player but you are the true heroes don't
lose your hope the world is with you we
care about you I am with you
so guys what you just saw there Subhan
Allah as you can see is that Subhan
Allah his message to the Syrian people
guys yeah why does this means a lot it
shows what kind of heart this man has he
has the wealth money all that kind of
stuff and players who have witnessed him
and his family see they're very humble
simple people very humble and simple
people Subhan Allah this is the reason
why brothers and sisters we ask Allah
subhana wa tala to guide this man to
Islam I've done a video about his
conversion to Islam close the the
goalkeeper claiming that he's going to
be very his interest is there make Dua
for him brother sisters and he's always
supported the Palestinian cause and he's
a is a person of for the people Subhan
Allah who cares who's donated is done so
much for the poor people around the
world be they Muslim or not so we ask
Allah subhana that let that be a means
to accept him accept in Islam and this
might be a key reason for him to accept
Islam brother and sisters that his
goodness of his heart and his generosity
is maybe the reason why brother and
sisters you know why because Allah tells
us in the Quran have you seen the one
who pushes away the orphan and doesn't
feed the needy and Allah equates that
also in a that the one who denies the
day of judgment Allah says the one the
one who denies the day of judgment
there's a correlation between him not
caring about the poor and his arrogance
subh this man is the opposite Subhan
Allah and we ask Allah subh to guide him
till next time brother and
sisters and may Allah subhana bless you
guys do not forget to inshallah download
the Quran app and get into the building
building a habit of reading the Quran so
next time Al